[in Ukrainian] People were lying in the fields, swollen
and so many dead people lay down on the road."
[in Ukrainian] I survived the Holodomor,
and will remember it as long as I live.
This is Rostyslav, reading the words of his
grandmother, Lydia, who lived in Ukraine.
[in Ukrainian] It was scary to watch and remember.
Lydia was a witness and survivor
of a horrific man-made famine that killed
millions in Ukraine.
My father has recorded an oral history that
his grandmother told him
and he just recorded it in ink pen.
[in Ukrainian] Our family consisted of 10 people.
[in Ukrainian] On one of those nights,
my father said that we would starve to death.
[in Ukrainian] We needed to do something.
The famine hit several parts of the
Soviet Union, from 1932 to 1933.
But in Ukraine it became known as "the Holodomor"
a term meaning “death by starvation".
It was genocide carried out by a dictator
who wanted to keep Ukraine under his control.
And would do everything in his power
to cover it up for decades.
In 1917, after the fall of the Russian empire,
Ukraine briefly gained freedom.
But, by 1922, it was forcefully integrated
into the newly formed Soviet Union
and became known as the
Ukrainian Socialist Soviet Republic.
At the time, the country was largely rural
most of the population were
villagers and farmers.
Self-reliance is a very important thing
for every Ukrainian.
And so having that piece of land,
cultivating that land
was something that was very important
to so many.
In fact, Ukraine was known for its farmland.
With some of the world’s most fertile soil,
the country was a huge grain producer
especially in these regions.
Over time, it became known as
the breadbasket of the Soviet Union
and Joseph Stalin wanted
complete control of it.
When Stalin rose to power in the mid-1920s
a distinctly Ukrainian culture and
national identity were thriving.
But by the late-1920s, he and other Soviet leaders
feared it could bring on a Ukrainian revolution.
They decided to crackdown on what they saw
as an ideological threat to the Soviet regime
and they began a widespread, violent purge
of Ukrainian intellectuals
along with priests, and religious structures.
You have to think about it as kind of
decapitating the leadership of the country.
You cut off its head, basically.
Around the same time, Stalin introduced a
“Five Year Plan”
that would eventually give him control of
Ukrainian agriculture.
The goal was to industrialize all of
the Soviet Union at a rapid pace
which meant building up industries like
electricity, coal, and steel.
To fund this project, Stalin turned to the
“collectivization” of agriculture.
Which meant consolidating
individual farms
across all of the Soviet Union
into large, state run farms.
If you combine, you know, 60, 70, 80
small farms into one big farm
it's easier to control it.
It's easier to extract surplus grain or surplus
sugar or whatever that farm produces.
In Ukraine, the plan gave Stalin direct control
over grain production
which meant he could extract all of the crop
to sell to the West
as a way to fund Soviet industrialization.
By this policy of industrialization, by taking
away everything that grew on the land
Stalin aimed to really destroy that connection
between the land and life itself.
That was one of the key ideological things
in industrialization
saying that it's not about the land,
it's about the state
the Soviet state that will then
provide for your livelihood.
Many Ukrainian farmers who had worked
independently for their entire lives
resisted Stalin’s plan.
So, Stalin found another way to attack them.
He launched a propaganda campaign
to smear farmers.
He labeled anyone resistant
to collectivization, a “kulak”
a Russian term for a wealthy peasant and depicted
them as greedy, exploiters,
and enemies of the state.
And sometimes, as literal parasites.
This is a way to drive a wedge within a community.
And it's a way to also justify, I think,
what the Soviet state
and what the Communist Party is trying to do
on the ideological side.
No matter how rich or poor, Stalin seized
the belongings of the so-called “kulaks".
He then exiled, imprisoned, or executed
hundreds of thousands of them.
And for the farmers who remained,
he engineered a famine to starve them.
In 1931, Stalin deliberately set quotas
for grain production
that were far beyond the capacity of farmers
across the Soviet Union.
When farmers failed to meet those quotas
Stalin's men swept their farms to confiscate
all the grain they could find.
Records show the Soviets took over 4 million
tons of grain from Ukraine alone in 1932.
That same year, a new law punished anyone
who took even a handful of grain
or was caught hiding grain or bread — with
10 years in prison, or the death penalty.
Stalin's oppressive collection policy created
a famine that started spreading
in grain-producing regions across
the Soviet Union.
Some party members sent Stalin letters
about the growing crisis
pleading for a change in policy.
And that's what makes it so diabolical because
if a government is really concerned
about its population, its people
then at the end of the first famine year,
it can reverse its policies.
But instead, the government and the party
actually doubled down.
Their commitment to collectivization
made the famine deadly in many parts
of the Soviet Union.
But when it came to Ukraine, Stalin's need
for the complete submission of its people
compounded the effects of the famine.
In the fall and winter of 1932, Soviet police
began seizing not just grain
but anything edible.
Even livestock.
Farms in Ukraine and sometimes entire villages,
were “blacklisted”
for missing grain quotas, torn apart for food,
and prohibited from receiving any supplies.
In January 1933, knowing Ukrainians were leaving
in search of food
Stalin closed the borders of Ukraine and policed
migration from Ukrainian villages to cities, too.
In the coming months, tens of thousands
of Ukrainian villagers
were caught trying to flee
and were sent back to their homes to starve.
This was a targeted extermination of peasantry.
People try to find food, you know, wherever
they could in rivers and streams.
They began to eat their animals, their pets.
They began to catch birds and mice, whatever
they could find on trees
that would give them some sort of sustenance.
People were so desperate that they ate
flesh from animals
that they found on the road
and some even resorted to cannibalism.
But even in this unimaginable suffering,
Ukrainians fought for their lives
and each other.
She was my great grandmother.
I have fond memories of her.
My dad took me to her village,
I was really young.
So Lydia's house is actually my first memories.
The way Holodomor happened, it was mostly
happening in the rural areas.
Lydia was a student at the time.
And she actually told me about how they survived.
[in Ukrainian] At night, we dug a hole under a tree.
[in Ukrainian] We put a barrel in the hole
and poured grain in there
and covered the barrel with soil.
At night they would make flour out of that
wheat and make some makeshift bread.
And the reason why they would do it at night
is that nobody could see
the smoke coming out of the windows.
Lydia describes horrific village scenes
seeing “a mother die of starvation” and
“police taking away children.”
Once, when Lydia saw her neighbors who had
“bloated bodies and couldn’t get up”
she started to sneak them “bread and milk".
It’s likely due to her efforts, that seven
people, out of that family of nine, survived.
After its peak in May and June of 1933,
the famine slowly started subsiding.
Likely because of a weakened labor force,
the Soviet regime
finally took measures to decrease
grain confiscations and arrests.
By 1934, most regions collectivized.
Almost all farmers were working for the state.
Though we will never know the total number
of deaths from the Holodomor
a recent study estimated nearly 4 million
Ukrainians killed.
Places like the North Caucasus, with a large
Ukrainian population, suffered greatly, too.
And further east, Kazakhstan lost at least
a third of its population.
So many people perished during the Holodomor
that the Soviet Union had to send people over
to Ukraine to rebuild the labor force.
The main goal was to resettle those areas
in order to work the land.
There were settlers brought in from various
parts of the Soviet Union
but mainly from Russia.
This resettlement program set off a wave of
future campaigns over the years.
Many Russians moved here in the east and south
which are, to this day, places with
large Russian populations.
In Russia, Stalin carried out
a massive disinformation campaign
to cover up the famine he'd created.
Throughout the crisis, he outright denied
that a famine ever took place.
He banned the Soviet press
from reporting on the famine
and banned foreign correspondents
from even going to Ukraine.
But, he strategically allowed language that
would effectively downplay the Holodomor
words like “food shortages” or
“food supply problems”.
For example, Walter Duranty — a Moscow correspondent
for the New York Times
who won a Pulitzer for his reporting on
Stalin’s success with the Five Year Plan
denied the famine in his reporting
calling it a “food shortage".
Duranty was challenged by others, including
journalist Gareth Jones
who snuck into Ukraine and wrote a series
of articles on how “famine ruled Russia".
At the time, Russia was a term
many journalists used
to describe the Soviet Union as a whole
including Ukraine.
Jones wrote: “Everywhere was the cry, 'there
is no bread.
We are dying.'”
In response — Duranty, who had more influence
than Jones, put out another article
this time insisting that “Russians were
hungry, but not starving".
Several photographers who also tried to expose
the humanitarian crisis
were arrested for their photos.
Some managed to get their images
to leaders in the West
but the images didn’t mobilize support
for Ukraine.
The West didn’t want to get involved in
Soviet politics.
The most cautionary tale is remembering that
the world didn't come to Ukraine's rescue.
It seemed like an internal issue.
There was a lot of misinformation, disinformation.
Outside of controlling the media narrative
Stalin destroyed archives
and made sure death certificates didn’t
use the word “starvation”
as a cause of death.
And then there was the case of the 1937 census
whose findings showed a drop
in the population of Ukraine.
So, Stalin decided that he couldn't allow
this to be made public.
The people who compiled the census
most of them were arrested and
some were even executed
and the census never became public.
Over the course of the next several decades
the Soviet Union continued to suppress
the Holodomor.
But in Ukraine, the truth was quietly passed
down through generations.
In more recent years, the Holodomor has been
recognized by more than a dozen countries
as a genocide.
In fact Raphael Lemkin, the researcher who
coined the term genocide
applied it to Ukraine on the basis of four reasons:
The extermination of intellectuals.
The destruction of churches and priests
The starvation of farmers.
And the fragmentation of Ukrainian people
through resettlement.
But the government of Russia has yet to acknowledge
any historical responsibility for the famine.
They've maintained — falsely — that the
famine hit Russia just as hard.
And today, similar tactics of disinformation
are being used to perpetrate
another violent attack against Ukrainians.
If one looks at the coverage provided by
Russian state media.
It seems like the Ukrainians keep shelling
themselves.
It seems like it's somehow the Ukrainians'
fault that there is this war in their own land.
It's war against our people.
I can't imagine, the second time we step
in the same river.
Whole cities right now in Ukraine
are being obliterated.
It is really my fear that if Russia were to
be successful in this current invasion of
Ukraine they will make sure that this page
of history is rewritten and is forgotten.